[Music]
all right jessica's starting off this
hour in milwaukee hi jessica how are you
hi i'm good how are you guys better than
we deserve what's up
um i'm calling because we are on baby
step two my husband and i we are really
close really close um but i
actually i think we only have one more i
think we are able to pay like by january
and we are debt-free yay good job i know
that part is exciting but i
am actually diagnosable anxiety disorder
adhd ocd just crazy and whenever it
kicks in i
start spending and
it's it's like i i almost want to say
it's almost like shopping addiction type
thing
it seems to hit whenever it's
like my something heavy with my mom
because she recently like passed away
about a year ago
and i don't know if
you guys have any advice about
our tips or anything to help me i just
don't want to ruin this for my husband
for my kids i don't know if you can hear
them giggling in the background but
you know it's so cool to be debt-free
and to be so close but every once in a
while it'll just be
just an overwhelming
you know sadness overwhelming
something and i don't know why but it
just turns into shopping and or spending
money on like the kids or the home or
something that i feel like i can control
and it's just you know any advice would
be helpful
so
number one thanks for being brave and
saying this out loud that's a big deal
right
um i want to
reframe the way you think about this is
that cool yes all right so i want you to
never again think about anxiety or
depression or ocd as something that
kicks in
because when something kicks in
uh like when our car goes to turbo
overdrive it just it's going to take off
on us and then we we are subject to that
i want to flip it around
and suggest this
anxiety that when the ocd gets gets hot
and and welcome to the club i've been a
member of many of the clubs you just you
just uh that you you're a member of too
yeah they are alarm systems and that's
it
all they're doing is notifying you of a
place in your life where you're out of
control where you can't control what
tomorrow's going to look like where
you're not safe or where you're
disconnected
and
what checks a lot of the couple of those
boxes if not all three of them is you
just lost your mom
right yeah and that's heavy and when you
think about that the alarm sound
and then
so your shopping is not a response to
the alarms your shopping is a response
to
grief
your shopping is a response to
i need to go do a thing because i'm
trying to avoid sitting and hurt and the
anxiety is that's just that's just an
alarm system okay
so
right
how have you grieved your mom's
passing um i mean
i guess yeah you're right i mean we
just were crying and i just vividly
remember i guess i really didn't face it
head-on because i do remember that there
were other people that seemed to be more
upset more breaking down than i was and
so i just literally remember being told
oh you have to hold it together because
we have to do this for my dad my dad was
having a really hard time so
so i think
everybody grieves differently
and yeah when when somebody passes away
you've got the responsibilities of
funerals and things like that but
you've got to honor this this trauma
this is a big deal i want you to write a
letter to your mom tonight
tell her how much you miss her
tell her how much
um 2022 is going to be different without
her what you're going to miss about her
and i want you to start healing there
and then put some roadblocks in front of
you give your debit card away if you've
got to in a hard season i've had to do
that give your debit card away set up
some roadblocks so that you don't spin